blut auf dem boden aufgerissene schränke
eine durchwühlte wohnung pure
verwahrlosung und es ist der ort an dem
bernard von bredow und seine 14-jährige
tochter lorena nicht nur umgebracht
sondern auch bestialisch gefoltert
wurden es ist das furchtbare ende eines
auswanderer traums vor vier jahren
wanderte archäologe mit seiner tochter
von bayern nach paraguay aus in einer
kleinstadt wollen sie neuanfang von
bredow kaufte ein grundstück und baut
ein haus doch die idylle wird zur hölle
ja vor gut zwei wochen am 22 oktober
werden sie überfallen gefoltert und
schließlich ermordet bisher ist der fall
ein absolutes mysterium es fehlt eine
spur und auch das motiv doch warum traf
es gerade bernhard von bredow und wer
war er überhaupt einen namen machte sich
der bayer vor allem in der archäologie
szene durch spektakuläre funde
1975 findet er überreste eines mammut
skelett er gründet ein urzeit museum
stellt dort seine schätze aus und nimmt
weltweit an ausgrabungen teil aber auch
abseits der archäologie war ein
tausendsassa er restaurierte flugzeuge
baute geigen und komponierte sogar
lieder jetzt das grausame ende seines
lebens vor dem haus in denen das
bestialische verbrechen geschah ist
jetzt unser kollege philipp lichterbeck
wie ist aktuell die situation
ja ich bin hier auf dem rund 1000
quadratmeter großen grundstück von
bernard bredow
das hat er vor vier jahren gekauft ich
weiß nicht ob ich gut ankomme ihr seid
ein bisschen verzögert aber das kriegen
wir schon hin fertig werde das
grundstück hat er vier jahren gekauft
und
hat hier verschiedene bauten errichtet
hinter mir hier links von mir ist das
haus in dem er oben im ersten stock mit
seiner tochter wohnte und in dem er auch
in dem die beiden brutal ermordet wurden
ich muss zugeben die ganze stimmung hier
ist etwas gruselig auf der einen seite
gehört das wahrscheinlich geht die sonne
auf die vögel zwitschern es ist grün und
auf der anderen seite wurden hier eben
vor kurzem noch zwei menschen brutal
ermordet
handels- und lagen dann mehrere stunden
in ihrer wohnung
was könnte denn das motiv seien darüber
wird wahrscheinlich auch in diesem dorf
spekuliert ist kann ja eigentlich kein
normaler überfall gewesen sein weil die
beiden wurden ja wirklich bestialisch
gefoltert wie wir eben auch schon gehört
haben
ja bislang ist ja eigentlich so gut wie
nichts über die hintergründe der tat
bekannt nur dass sie eben
unbeschreiblich brutal war ich konnte
selbst einen blick oben hier in die
wohnung werfen und der mord geschah und
daher ist ein ziemliches chaos tausend
sachen liegen durcheinander es welche
kleidung möbel kissen geschirr
und im blut lachen über alles blut ist
sind überall bluttropfen die brutalität
der täter die folterung der bauausschuss
an der tochter die hinrichtungsart igge
inszenierung deutet im grunde auf eine
nachricht hin des organisierten
verbrechens
es ist im grunde sieht es aus wie ein
ein mafia wars nur dahin schritt
überhaupt keine piste und es gibt auch
überhaupt keine bekannten verbindung von
bredow in das organisierte
kriminelle verbrechens mir hier was weiß
man denn über ihn überhaupt da es ja
eine rätselhafte persönlichkeit was hat
er in paraguay gemacht ja das stimmt er
ist wirklich etwas rätselhaft er wird
hier beschrieben als genialer kauz als
tausendsassa als liebenswerter
eigenbrötler er konnte angeblich über
alles reden über philosophie über
paläontologie
über physik er war aber auch
handwerklich enorm talentiert konnte
motoren auseinandernehmen er konnte
autos reparieren und vor allen dingen
konnte er instrumente bauen er war
instrumente bauen und reparieren auch
unter spielte auch geige man ein
weiterer spitzname von ihrem ort hier
war der geigen bernard hier in arango an
diesem ort holte bern hat eine neue
existenz aufbauen für sich und seine
tochter ihnen schwebt hier auf diesem
grundstück man sieht ja auch die groß
das ist hinter mir ist noch ein weiteres
gebäude im schriftlichen akademie vor in
die er seine vielen freunde aus aller
welt insbesondere die musiker einladen
wollte wichtig zu nennen ist vielleicht
noch die beziehung zu seiner tochter
hier war alles league geliebt hat das
höre ich immer wieder und diese tochter
muss internet oft ein polizist vorbei
und diese tochter muss also auch ein
ganz toller mensch gewesen sein ähnlich
begabte ähnlich interessiert in alle
richtungen wie ihr vater das meiste was
weiß man denn über die mutter ist die
auch mit ausgewandert oder lebt die nach
wie vor in deutschland nein wir sind
getrennt schon seit vielen jahren und
bredow ist eben mit seiner jüngsten
tochter hierher gekommen die anderen
drei kinder sind schon erwachsen
ist die frage wie reagieren denn die
einwohner des dorfes auf diesen
schrecklichen fall
ja hier herrscht jetzt eine mischung aus
bestürzen aus verunsicherung und gut
bestürzen einmal weil man hier so etwas
nicht erwartet hat februar ist
eigentlich ein recht beschauliche ort
und leute ich werde immer wieder
angesprochen und leute sagen mir wie
schrecklich sie das alles finden hat
sich auf dem friedhof am grab der beiden
kamen drei frauen auf mich zu mir das
gesagt ich war dann noch auf dem
polizeikommissariat später und da sagte
mir der polizist dass so etwas hier
komplett ungewöhnlich sei das hat er in
acht jahren noch nicht erlebt es sei
zwar üblich dass ein gebrochen würde
aber die täter würden nicht gewalttätig
werden und würden es vermeiden aufsehen
zu erregen es gibt hier eine kleine
deutsche gemeinde von 100 bis 150
menschen der ort hat 40.000 einwohner
insgesamt und dort herrscht große
verunsicherung viele dieser deutsche
sind deutschen sind hierhergekommen auf
der suche nach einem einem friedlichen
ort für die zweite lebenshälfte und die
wissen jetzt nicht nur ob sie hier
wirklich noch am richtigen ort sind
viele von denen haben sich tatsächlich
jetzt auch bewaffnet drittens sind viele
menschen wütend das ist klar man möchte
dass der täter gefunden wird und zu
diesem zweck wurde jetzt sogar ein
kopfgeld von den deutschen und einer
sicherheitsfirma hier ausgelobt die zur
ergreifung der täter führen soll von
insgesamt 15.000 dollar kurioserweise
soll das auch die polizei ansporn
gründlicher nach den tätern zu fahnden
weil in paraguay muss man leider sagen
auch schwerste verbrechen leider häufig
nicht aufgeklärt werden für nämlich kein
werk live aus paraguay über diesen
rätselhaften oder schrecklichen fall
danke philipp